The Voice openly calls out superhero
cliches and gets really meta about comic
books and we love it from MCU potshots
to Justice League shoutouts here are
small details that only true fans notice
about Amazon's the boys it doesn't take
long to get familiar with these
superheroes or Supes in the world of the
boys because we already know them the
production is counting on the fact that
its audience is already familiar with
the slew of superheroes that have
quickly become mainstream over the past
few years thus many of the Supes need no
introduction or explanation we know that
home Lander is a Superman clone the deep
is this world's Aquaman and Queen Maeve
is Wonder Woman watts the seven are
clearly DC's Justice League so where are
the Avengers they exist we learn through
a quick quip from starlight you may have
overlooked in Episode one starlight
worries that the Crimson countess got
the open position in the seven rather
than her besides countess probably got
it so good but crimson countess is a
member of the Avengers asked superhero
team called payback and she's an obvious
riff on Scarlet Witch the vision loving
Avenger played by Elizabeth Olsen
producer Eric Kripke likes to marry
comedy to horror and slapstick to drama
this expert weaving of action with witty
one-liners is clear from the show's he's
produced from Supernatural to the boys
both of these shows feature memorable
tough guys taking on supernaturally
powered people they also both feature a
character named Robert singer played by
Jim beaver Jim beaver has been a part of
each and every production that Kripke
has had his hand in in supernatural
beaver plays fan-favorite character
Bobby singer a cantankerous old hunter
of demons ghouls and vampires with a
fatherly influence on the show's wayward
main characters and the boys beaver
appears in the final episode of season 1
as the secretary of defense also named
Robert singer as if his appearance alone
wasn't enough of a nod to his previous
role in a Kripke hit show the boys
reveals that superhero business
functions a lot like show business soups
aren't vigilantes dedicated to justice
instead their highly managed talent akin
to Hollywood actors but doesn't allow
them to choose where they Patrol who
they save or even what they where all
that is handled by an expert team of
marketers who look to statistics social
media and stocks and deciding
loop's to make in Episode three
starlight is given a new costume by
Vaught that is a little more revealing
than what she's comfortable with so vote
VP Madeline Stillwell brings in Seth and
Evan from marketing to try to sell her
on the plunging neckline these names are
likely purposeful nods to the big names
behind the boys executive producers Seth
Rogen and Evan Goldberg Rogen even makes
an appearance in the boys as himself and
a promotion for the latest film in the
VCU we learn in Episode six that Huey
wasn't the only person adversely
affected by the superpowers of Supes as
Billy butcher brings him to an
association of collateral damage
survivors meeting in a setup that looks
a lot like an Alcoholics Anonymous
meeting survivors recount their rescues
gone wrong and bad encounters with Supes
the wheelchair-bound woman talking as
they come in says that she wishes that a
soup named tech night would have been a
little more gentle with her spine in the
comics tech night is a kind of mashup
between Batman and Iron Man he has a
mansion a butler in a secret cave
however he also flies around in a
super-powered metal suit and has an
uncontrollable libido that causes chaos
14 payback when it comes to this
survivor of collateral damage it's
possible that this is a dark reference
to what happened with rody in the MCU as
he was shot out of the sky and crippled
and Captain America Civil War leading
him to wearing high-tech leg braces and
Shore vision is the one who shot rody
down but ultimately it was Iron Man's
fault
in episode 6 of the boys we learn that
not all superheroes are super famous
some can be just as washed-up as any old
actor for example Mother's Milk goes to
the heroes and headliners autograph show
up the american adventures in in order
to seek out charles who's better known
as Mesmer Mesmer has the power to read
someone's mind just by touching them but
his days of stardom are long gone he was
a child actor on an old show called the
mesmerizer in which he read the minds of
criminals the mesmerizer looks an awful
lot like law and order but it also riffs
openly on the show that gave Neil
Patrick Harris a start
Doogie Howser MD in which he played a
kid doctor Mesmer's character named in
the mesmerizer is even lieutenant Howser
it's notable to that adult Mesmer is
portrayed by Haley Joel Osment who's
best known for the roles he played as a
child
in Episode three of the boys we learn
who the fastest man alive really is sort
of rumors had been going around that
shockwave was actually faster than the
seventh a train whose only power is
speed but when the two race a train
ultimately cheats by using a
performance-enhancing super drug because
being slower than shockwave would mean
that his place in the seven would come
into question after all why would the
best of the best have the second fastest
man alive this amazing race is a
reference to the many races that the
flash and Superman have in the comics to
see who was truly the speediest
speedster most recently this friendly
rivalry was featured as a mid credit
scene in the Justice League movie with
the flash and Superman getting ready to
race to the coast
Superman jokes that the stakes are high
but if I win you're off the team for
much of the series we see votes vice
president Madeline Stillwell making all
the calls when it comes to the seven and
the other superheroes the company
manages BOTS president known only as mr.
Edgar remains mysterious until the final
episode of season one it turns out that
mr. Edgar is played by Giancarlo
Esposito best known for his role as the
villain Gustavo Fring and Breaking Bad
mr. Edgar gives Stillwell a bonus and
some new responsibilities obviously
grooming her to eventually take his
place he says that someone will have to
be around to run the show when he moves
to the tropical Central American nation
of Belize this might seem like an
innocent turn of phrase but Breaking Bad
fans know better as Walter White and
Saul Goodman used going to Belize as
code for having someone killed sent him
to police I'll send you to police maybe
this is a subtle hint that by the end of
the series the Vaught president will be
in the grave rather than on a sunny
beach check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bow so you don't miss a single one
[Music]